hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to berry now we're
about to begin chapter 4 and things are
really really dire to recap we're going
back up to the command center to open
the hangar bay doors which I don't know
why we didn't do but we didn't do that
the ride of the elevator is tense I take
a series of deep breaths doing
everything I can to stay in control amy
has gone back to her feet but her head
is pressed against the elevator wall as
she suppresses a series of sobs I find
myself trying to remember the way those
creatures looked but my mind seems to
shudder the effort I've seen something
that is an impossibility a mockery of
what I know is real this fills me with
tears of course anything else I've felt
since discovering the facility I try to
focus on my mind my mind on something
else and remember Marcus's threats
I will never foreseen Marcus again I say
mostly to myself do you think Marcus got
away from those things I sort of hope
not me too she says looking at the
ground her arms folded so I say how did
you end up here
she gives the nervous chuckle and shrugs
I used to work with the Pentagon it was
some pretty upper echelon stuff but I
still can't discuss I assume this place
is even more upper echelon this place
isn't even on the scale she answers my
other job with a cakewalk compared to
this and why stay I ask because the
money is ridiculous I have a 13 year old
daughter already talking about Harvard
you do the math any other kids no just
the one
her dad split on us when she was 3 I
never remarried so no siblings for her I
may have only gotten one but the one I
got is amazing Amy pauses before
continuing this awfully
what if I never see her voice breaks off
the words too terrible to say her eyes
filled with tears the elevator comes to
a stop the slight ping of it
interrupting the moment ami hastily
wipes her eyes and we waste no time
getting it back inside the command
center I ready the rifle suddenly
certain that there more of those
creatures waiting for us in the hallway
of the second level the way is clear
allowing us to haul ass to the command
center once again I find myself staring
at the screen that shows my ruined work
sight
okay okay this is Titan commands rapidly
it can't be that hard keep peeking over
my shoulder
my sensors feeling is that the monster
sneaking up on us mere inches away
I can't think to Dennis and wonder how
he's faring back on level three if he's
safe I look back to the screens see that
amy has finally found what she's looking
for
bronze on the screen says override of
hangar doors in all level three locks
requires clearance code Amy types in a
number with shaking fingers and the
screen goes blank for a moment the
moment the words override confirm come
up on the screen
Amy jumps up on the chair and we head
out of the room we have to be quick she
says we have exactly 20 minutes to open
those hangar doors well you know what I
don't think I need to know what happens
in 20 minutes I think I know what
happens in 20 minutes I follow her out
of the command center and bound back to
the hallway towards the same elevator
that brought us here Amy punches the
elevator button of the doors slide open
we're taking the same elevator back to
the biochem room those creatures are
still down there it's the only way back
down the other way is blocked by those
hydraulic doors we pulled hopefully the
creatures left hopefully neither of us
say anything else as we share a look of
immense dread we step back into the
elevator and head back down to the bio
chem room on level
well damn that was a quick go of things
oh this is not gonna be good I hope we
find Marcus's body maybe they went after
him considering that he was alive maybe
they went after him and didn't decide to
bother us as the elevator doors open we
peer out looking to see if the creatures
still in the area but it's all clear
when Amy looks at me her eyes are clear
and strong Marcus wasn't entirely wrong
Amy says that we started walking
backwards a hangar about what I am about
how I'm partially to blame for this why
would you be to blame I mean you're
doing a science but you didn't know some
of the things we do here it's scary we
should have known that one day something
like this would happen
everyone here with knowledge of what's
going on in level 3 is to blame she says
it's a highly advanced research facility
I say doing amazing but risky stuff so
yeah you're partially to blame by just
working here but I can understand the
dedication so why don't you tell me a
bit more about what does go on in level
3 I asked are you familiar with the
Large Hadron Collider over in
Switzerland I've heard of the phrase but
that's about it
it's a powerful particle accelerator
right now they're using it to try to
create what's called Dark Matter it's
theorized that this Dark Matter actually
makes up the majority of the universe
but parts of the universe very different
from ours my guess is the people at the
LHC will probably create their first
Dark Matter particle in about 2018 or
2019 here in this research facility we
were able to create one almost 10 years
ago it was the key to our research that
does have something to do with those
things
well we still don't know all there is
about dark matter or other matter we
haven't yet identified these creatures
could be made of it or maybe there are
even some even more exotic matter
we just don't know if dark matter is
responsible there are no real answers to
have I scratch my head so you're saying
this dark matter helps with what opening
up other dimensions or something that's
the theory she says during the
point-to-point transfer the subjects are
gone for about three to six seconds
there's no way to see or measure their
presence but they exist somewhere from
what we can tell they exist in a kind of
void have you done this with people we
have sent human subjects through almost
all of them have returned successfully I
make an involuntary grimace almost there
was one man dr. Kenna who didn't return
we don't know where she trails off
taking a moment to collect yourself
sorry I asked I say feeling my mind
start to bend inward again as we
continue to walk between the silos we
walk past the area where we left Marcus
behind but he's long gone maybe he found
a way out I realized that we're walking
very close together between the silos
perhaps trying to create the illusion of
safety we reach the exit connecting to
the hangar doors where Denis hopefully
still is like a clench in my heart
hammers at my chest as we open the door
and walk through I lift the rifle but at
first it seems that there's nothing
waiting for us that's when I see the
glowing hoping shape to my left closing
in fast oh [ __ ]
the creature is left and feet away and
coming in quickly so I do the first
thing that comes to mind
I dropped to the ground making myself a
smaller target and raised the rifle I'm
not sure if I should just unload on the
master try to be choosy with my shots to
weaken it or at least slow down shoot to
weaken obviously we're not going to be
able to kill these things that's why I
shot at the things before because I know
that it can be slowed down but not kill
my shot causes the entity milkie entire
milky-white frame to jerk to the floor
it flounders its goods like tentacles
writhing with rage as Christ's doctor
seems to turn and jerk away parts of it
appearing disappearing every few feet it
moves down the hall and out of sight
they look quickly around for others but
there's only Amy she looks at where the
monster went with wide eyes her face is
pale and I wonder if like me she is able
to feel her mind trying to retreat come
on I say let's find Dennis and get
through these hangar doors maybe glances
at her watch we're already down to 6
minutes we turned towards the hangar
doors and I'm a little disgusted with
myself because the bloody scene that's
so shocked me before now seems mild and
he goes to work on the computer consult
on the left side of the doors
she starts punching in keys before
saying this is going to take some time I
thought you already unlocked it I asked
I did she said but for this door there's
still security permissions I need to
hack markets would have known how to do
this she trails off and I decide to let
her work suddenly something slammed into
me I feel my feet leave the floor and
I'm literally thrown across the concrete
I look up there's in time to see one of
the creatures it's apparently in no
hurry to attack me again focusing on Amy
instead she's not armed I need to come
up with a plan to get this thing away
from her so she could focus on getting
the door open
it raises one of its flickering
appendages making me certain a part of
its makeup it's pure light and energy
I could easily take a shot with my rifle
but my mind again goes to how much
remaining mammal I have the only other
thing I can think of is to get it to
chase me and lead it away from this
world somehow I guess I could distract
it it seems to be very important right
now to conserve my ammo so if I can
distract it then I can get out of here
hey I kill right here come get me I'm
the one that shot your buddy it turns to
me and I am again faced with the staring
at something that is no business in this
world in this reality its body gives
also sort of glow around the central
part a bulbous core that's branched off
into two humps very much like a spider
again our senses as visual information
is not accurate but it's the best my
simple mind can do to make sense of this
impossible creature it starts lurching
towards me lets out a shriek of agony
that makes me feel like my ears are
going to explode now that I'm sure it's
coming after me I take off running and
head into another hallway we haven't
been down I find myself in an industrial
looking area and pleased to find that
the monster has followed me through
oh I'm pleased at that oh that's a good
thing okay alright then great oh boy the
room seems to be an assortment of old
pipes and tanks I assume some of them
run further down into the other areas of
the facility with the creature on my
tail I dash into the maze of metals
hoping to lose it it's definitely having
a harder time squeezing through than I
am and that slows it down
of course the rooms not a cage of any
kind the thing is still heading towards
me shredding through the pipes at rages
I noticed that sometimes it's breaking
the steel girders but other times it
seems like it's somehow merging or
changing them pipes that were separate
are now connected together in a way that
makes my head hurt I finally get a good
amount of distance between myself and
the creature
I think it's lost my trail I need to get
back to those hangar doors there's not
much time before the closed shut if I
make a sound that creature would be on
my heels again I'm going to run as fast
as I can because frankly I need to get
there before they close but maybe I only
had six minutes again and that's
probably like four minutes ago I got a
go I got a book it there's no time I
think to myself I have to get moving
with no care of staying silent I twist
myself loosing more pipes and make my
way back towards the door I entered
immediately the creature picks up on
this and turns towards me but I don't
even look back I fly through this rust
in the obstacle course and sprint back
to the hangar doors
yep let's do that let's do that let's do
that I burst back into the large room
see Amy's still working on the computer
terminal by the hangar doors you okay I
asked Amy I can clearly see you're
battling for control of her faculties
steel determination wins out and she
give the grim nod any sign of where
dennis when I asked hoping she has
noticed his body somewhere
no she replies it's then that I realized
that I have no idea how many rounds
remaining in the rifle this isn't a
model I'm familiar with outside of some
gear I'm not much of an expert on
firearms still let me locate the chamber
easily and see that there were only two
rounds left I find when we cursed myself
for being to trigger happy earlier how
are we on time I asked her four minutes
I'm going as fast as I can
I was worried how long it would take you
to lose that thing well I decided it was
better to get back quickly than didn't
at that moment the creature screams on
the other side of the door he'll be in
here any second Amy does our best to
focus on the keyboard but there's still
no sign of Dennis before I have time to
look around it screeching sound erupts
from the other side of the robot
I bring the rifle up in a shooter stance
and turn around with the hanger doors
right behind me no sign of damage than
closing window time I have to be
confident yet when two monsters come
around the corner of my body wants to
shut down the appendages seem to jump in
space sometimes reaching out for a split
second independent of the body and then
disappearing back to where they came
from
it turns and screeches actually it's
glowing tentacles sneaking out of its
body my knees tremble uncontrollably
find me Amy shrieks I feel myself losing
control my mind sliding into the abyss
of insanity I pull myself back from the
brick I've got to stay in control I've
only got two shots left now would be the
time to use them
[Music]
two bullets two monsters okay I'll take
that chance I step away from Amy in the
hangar doors and towards the monster
ready to defend her I ready my rifle but
the creatures waste no time it makes
that jerky motion towards me
there's a sharp pain in my chest that
collides with me or through me it's hard
to tell my instinct is to try to grapple
or hold this thing down but then I
realized I don't even know if that would
work
boy my guess is that touching this thing
is probably not a good idea I'm gonna
try to get away I figure I'd rather not
try to learn more about the physical
nature of this thing right now I tuck
and roll away from and then stand up to
face it with a scream of defiance I've
raised the rifle and put around in a
core the shot lands dead center in the
light inside of it flickers almost
violently it falls back against the wall
issuing a history of its telltale static
noise then jerks away and retreats at
least for now another terror appears
that missed out as if out of nowhere
screaming at me with its high-pitched
whine it bounds forward charging in a
strange [ __ ] way I am the rifle
tending to take this one on in the core
- I take several shots which is coming
at me as it slams into me I pull the
trigger again and realize that my rifle
is now empty on contact the wind is
knocked out of my lungs in the back of
my head strikes the floor and either of
these things is alarming is the fact the
Beast is on top of me its exterior is
like a seashell that's been pounded by
the surf for so long it's lost all edges
and ridges but the grip it tries to
capture me with pure violence
I feel those lights soaked depending to
start to wrap around me I've raised the
rifle knowing it's empty but hoping to
use it as a wedge was gonna knock me the
weight of the monster is a Braddock one
moment of your weightlessness another I
feel like I'm going to be crushed
I push upward with the rifle the monster
budget debate but almost seems to absorb
it warping in its grip I see the core of
the body a spider-like shape connected
to the rest of it by a thin white string
of tissue I'll be dead within seconds
unless I can fend it off
what's Amy gonna do Amy doesn't have
anything she's got open those doors with
punch - [ __ ] let's just punch it I do
my best to keep one last heave to push
it off with my hand smell true I cursed
myself for wasting so many bullets
earlier two of its appendages wrap
around my left shoulder and I feel a
white-hot aim fill my body the tentacles
burned and I realized that some are
actually going through my shoulder like
a kid pulling apart the stitches of a
doll then I see the creature extend its
tentacles in aggravation while making
that static screeching sound the
creature flickers releasing me suddenly
with a shudder and a cry of desperation
I roll away from it and see that a large
hole of the period in its lunes core the
creature disappears into thin air and
repairs a few feet from me we're
treating back towards the bio camera Amy
looks over at me from a terminal at the
hangar doors looking petrified dennis
stands several feet away holding a
shotgun he walks slowly towards us and
is clearly just as scared and out of
sorts as we are the okay Bob he asked
his eyes on on me they're looking to the
creature trying to understand what
exactly it is you see about 15 minutes
ago I heard the door to that main into
him on lock Dennis says pointing to the
room I tried to bust my way into earlier
ah Amy says when I did the override up
in the command center and unlocked all
the small doors down including that
maintenance room I went inside there and
hid Dennis continues and while is
waiting for you to come back I found a
massive trunk there are a few guns in it
so I grabbed this one padding
good man Dennis I'm glad you're safe
Dennis Jesus but instead thanks boss
me too she doesn't break eye contact
with the panel almost done she replies
suddenly without warning a shot
ricochets off the wall behind Amy's
hadn't started we look around confused
did Dennis gun go off we when another
shot blasts mears again we all drop to
the floor I look around wondering who or
what could possibly be shooting at us
those creatures don't do anything that
sounds remotely like gunfire and then I
see him Marcus I should have killed him
when I had the chance he has a rifle and
is walking towards us an insane look in
his eyes you all deserve to die he
screams unleashing another round that I
gear whizzed by my head Dennis doesn't
hesitate he stands up and shoots at
markets causing him to retreat how much
longer a me [ __ ] markets almost there
she says quietly she makes a few final
key presses and says done the doors open
with the noise hydraulics and a whoosh
of air with Marcus pinned down by
Dennis's gunfire we start moving towards
the door at that moment another creature
jerks into existence around the corner
between us and Marcus [ __ ] Marcus says
it starts unloading into it but then he
learns the same lesson we did this only
slows the creature down Marcus gives us
one last look then turns and runs off in
another direction
Dennis Amy and I climb up and head
through the doors moving on nothing more
than a rental in I see you look
longingly at the maintenance room Dennis
- a shotgun
you get in the hangar I'll get some more
firepower satisfied with the plan
Amy heads through the door we scramble
inside finally inside the hangar annex
approaches from behind holding several
guns and looking like a kid who crammed
an armful of Halloween candy
Amy reach out for reaches out for a
9-millimeter with one hand Dennis turned
to me and hold out shotgun and a handgun
for me to choose bolt with deadly the
shotgun looks more powerful but the
handgun will probably be more precise
then it's already has the shotgun he's
good with that that's his baby I'll take
the handgun
I select the handgun and uncomforted by
the way it seems to fit perfectly in my
shaky grip it's more creatures coming as
many as a dozen they're floating down
the hall quickly their tentacles
slithering it the way their light seems
to mingle together is almost beautiful
close the door I yell at Amy she dashes
to another terminal mounted on the
inside of the hangar door tries
desperately to close them it's not
working she says with tears in her eye
this terminal is disabled dennis looks
through the open doors readying himself
just shooted the first monster that
needs us
should we try to slow a few down or just
run for it he asked gun at the ready if
if we slow them down there's a chance
I'm not going to make the mistake off I
don't know should we
it looks like ah Clark so the terminal
is disabled there's no way shooting at
them is going to give us enough time
like to close it so I say we just go for
it good idea so hear me with that we
turn around and sprint out onto the
hangar floor that's not to waste ammo
again I learned that lesson
the room is enormous so large that
called a room seems silly a large
concrete floor stretches out below an
expansive locked-in ceiling the area is
mostly empty except for one time which
has rows and rows of metal barrels back
in the far wall is a lit area that seems
to expose more rooms labs and machinery
also in the rear of the hangar I can see
come some kind of chamber or control
center Dennis and I follow Amy across a
hangar floor behind us a series of rough
slithering sounds tells us that the
creatures have made their way into the
hangar from somewhere up ahead a loud
buzzing really sounded out
it reminds me of the slight lovely Lloyd
I heard in the forest the noise that got
me into all this trouble in the first
place I look ahead and see that in the
far back of the hangar a bright red
light is flashing
there's a small hatch or door below the
light the hatch is open again
he is shape inside of it I can barely
make out the figure of a man standing
there holding an industrial microphone
as soon as I see him I hear his huge
huge amplified voice it blares down over
an intercom system any sound is I don't
know who the hell you are he says but
this is a government facility on
lockdown and there are protocols to ship
I assume the curse coincides with the
exact moment he sees the creatures
they're making their way through the
hangar doors there are maybe 20 feet
between us and the creatures I act
instinctively firing twice as the
handgun comes alive in my hand one shot
goes into the core one monster causing
it to jerk backwards another shot slows
down a creature the accuracy I get with
the 9-millimeter is amazing Amy and
Dennis take
start firing as well the floor becomes
littered with a swirling white fluid
from the wounded creatures body but they
are not slowing down the alarm keeps
screeching behind us and when I turn to
see if anything has changed back there I
tripped over my feet I hit the ground
hard and in the most comic fashion slide
several feet across the floor from the
ground I see what we have managed to
turn back four of them I also see to my
estimate the Dozen is off there are at
least 20 of them they're sick dim light
sinister and gloomy their appendages
seem to bind together as they come
forward my only hope of survival is that
the man in the Far doorway have somehow
shuts the hangar doors his voice comes
blaring over the intercom again broken
by the booming noise of gunfire were
laying down run here towards the
isolation chamber I'm not sure how much
time we have I realized I can sprint
ahead of Amy and Dennis
or I can hang back and give them cover
I'm going to keep shooting to cover the
others Dennis can't run he's still
injured I have to remember that go
inside where that guy is I'll make sure
we don't have any of those things right
on our tail
I'll hold them back for a while I know
it sounds macho but it also feels like
the right thing to do I have to at least
try to give us some kind of chance to
escape
so as Amy and Dennis run through the
doors I blast the next thing that I see
moving all I get from my troubles are
that static like hiss and high-pitched
whistling noise I'm able to beat them
back a bit forcing them to scattered
each flicker of light is a small victory
if nothing else I'm buying Amy and
Dennis time when I'm certain there's
nothing more I can do I turn and run I
hustle
quickly catching up to Amy and Dennis
who stop and turn to provide me with
cover fire there Amy says pointing to
the small door where the man was
standing earlier the swarm is less than
15 feet away so furious that they're
pushing through one another to get to us
I raise the hand gun fire taking my time
to aim I hit one in the spider-like part
of his body I fire again this time
taking one in the core I placed two more
rounds into this creature eventually
causing it to move back
we're in the middle of the hangar floor
now with the isolation chamber ahead two
monsters behind us
beside me Dennis also fires the kick of
the gun Schultz probably a result of it
being weakened from the blood loss his
shot lands true though causing a jerking
stumble in the flickering of its leg
we're almost saying Amy yells as we get
close to the door we hope will save us
Dennis and Amy get in that [ __ ] door
get inside I tell Amy and Dennis
motioning for them to get moving with my
gun I open the door and give Dennis a
push towards it he resists more eager to
try taking down another one of the
beasts before he makes it to safety but
eventually gives it a way to beat to
make sure Amy is inside - I fire off a
few rounds on the creatures that are
still headed for us hoping to slow them
down when Amy and Dennis clear the door
I nearly - inside but then feel
something hot seep into my back Roger
Dennis yells the pain in my back is so
immense that I barely noticed the fact
that I'm being lifted from the floor I
look down and see the one of the
creatures was using exploding arms to
grab me by the waist its tentacles
wrapping around me it lifts me into the
air as if presenting me as a trophy to
its friend I tried to focus attempting
to angle my arm in a way that allowed me
to aim the handgun in place a bullet in
its body but it's shaking me violently
and it's other parts are appearing and
disappearing in a way that makes no
sense another oddity of its structure I
can literally do nothing more than hang
there like a rag doll hoping to be saved
as it continues to hoist me up
screeching its approval and it comes
back out the woman fires on the shot the
bullet catches the monster on the
underside of its core sending it
backwards and causing it to freeze for a
moment it releases me and I hit the
ground
dropping my gun in again finding myself
unable to breathe
I feel slightly busy but that fades when
I see Dennis was still standing outside
the door he's firing into the Beast like
a madman doesn't see the one to his left
coming along the edge of the wall push
him out of the way god I push him down
no time to call Absalom I tried to dash
towards Stannis to put them out of the
way but there's not enough time Oh
the creature jerks out of existence and
then weird reappears right behind them
at the time Dennis turns and sees the
creature coming it's already drawn
several appendages active strike Dennis
tries to raise his gun but it's knocked
away by one two tentacles a second
chemical strikes and Dennis is spun
around and thrown off balance by the
attack
Dennis catches himself before falling
the third tentacle wraps around Dennis's
forum and I can see it squeezed
tightening instantly the tippity
appendage passes clean through his hand
his blood-soaked tip poking out through
his palm Dennis's face grimaces with
pain as he tries the wrenches on to
freeze but the creatures tentacles it
has its hands speared like a nail
through wood in a moment of dark clarity
I realize that I can frame with a clean
shot at the monstrous tentacle it will
likely mean blowing Dennis hands off
Dennis I yell a bit creatures can you
get free I have a shot maybe no don't
shoot I can get free as the creature
tosses around by his hand like a puppet
I can't tell if he's right but the other
monsters are starting to encircle them I
need to expand fast I'm going to shoot
that asset and off Dennis
I'm not gonna lieutenant I'm not gonna
lose them I'm gonna take action here
you're sorry sorry sorry Dennis if I
don't take the shot while I have it
they're going to kill him in a
last-ditch effort I try getting a good
shot on the monster but there is none
I'll hurt Dennis even worse if I try I
take aim and fire off a shot the shot
lands perfectly in adults in a lot of
blood and screams from Oh Dennis and the
creature Dennis's hand disappears into a
spray of red and the monsters appendage
simply fade away
it literally seems to wink out of
existence the creature screeches well
Dennis it's the floor wailing in pain
the reality of what I've done set to
merely paralyzed me get a magnet
I'll cover you I'm not reeling from the
sight of what I've done the Dennis I
stumble out of the door Amy is true to
her word she fires off a few rounds
under the approaching monsters as I make
it to Dennis I grab ahold of them with
like do it on a dragon backwards as fast
as I can
nearly falling down in the process when
I reached the doorway amy reaches down
that helps me drag his body the final
few people in the room
she manages to pull off another shot
when I see when I look to see what she's
hit I seen another dozen or so of the
monsters dennis is writhing in pain when
he looks up at me
he's sneering you crazy [ __ ] he
screams he shudders violently sweat and
tears coursing down his pale face
Amy slams the door behind us finally
were inside the room hopefully safe
within what looks like to be an
isolation chamber of sorts along the
frame a little electrical lock beeps at
the door is secured and I'm chapter 4
there is no way I am NOT going to shoot
off his hand like [ __ ] no if you are one
of my good friends at least in a
survival scenario you're one of my good
friends I am NOT going to let you risk
being torn to pieces in front of my eyes
when I could I could fricken shoot you
in the hand and oh man ho boy and good
thing I had the handgun because that's
the only way that I could have been
accurate okay so let's do a post mortem
of all these different things
self-control play a shot to weaken the
creature not to kill it because there
was no point in killing it I learned
that I couldn't kill it from me shooting
at it before so there was no point in me
even trying keep them at bay
7:41 percent of players distracted the
creature instead of shooting it again
can't waste my ammo I didn't have any
left weapon of choice
preferably Dennis with shotgun man and
you know maybe he can use a shotgun with
a stump arm and another good hand but
you know I did what I had to do there
and especially on the judgment call he
was dangling in air they were looming
over him how in the world would he have
gotten away from that there's no way an
injured man like that would have gotten
away he would have been killed or maybe
he wouldn't have I have no idea I'm not
going to take that risk you know what I
mean I'm just not going to do that so I
had to take the shot but either way
that's that's how I did there so let me
know how you did if you're playing this
game for yourself and let me know how
you think I did and reasoning for going
one way or another because most of these
choices I found are an even 50/50 split
so thanks again so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video
bye-bye
[Music]